cette semaine dans les salles obscures
on retrouve alibi.com 2 une comédie qui
signe le retour de la bande à Fifi
portée par le succès du premier opus le
réalisateur et acteur Philippe lacheau
revient avec ses camarades de toujours
mais aussi avec Nathalie Baye Arielle
Dombasle Gérard Jugnot ou encore Gad
Elmaleh si à la fin du premier volet
Greg avait promis à sa compagne Flo qui
ne lui mentirait plus jamais et qu'il
fermerait définitivement alibi.com son
agence spécialisée dans le mensonge sa
demande en mariage pourrait bien changer
la donne en fait ma belle-famille veut
absolument que mes parents soient
présents au mariage
mais si tu as honte on peut faire un
alibi famille on loue des fois parents
comme on a fait pour le fils de Francis
Lalan hors de question les alibi c'est
terminé
[Musique]
suivez-moi je vous prie
le monde entier toi foire ce qu'on a
fait à mon fils
les photos elles ont transformé la vie
des gens
donc la tension est braqué sur vous
maintenant le film d'animation
sacrémomie de Juan Jesus Garcia galocha
devrait ravir les plus jeunes dans cette
comédie des momies égyptiennes venus
d'un royaume enchanté vont voyager
jusqu'au Londres d'aujourd'hui objectif
récupéré une bague de mariage subtilisé
par un archéologue en effet la princesse
néfert est promise à un ancien pilote de
chars qu'elle déteste et ses réciproque
mais en compagnie du frère de tut et de
son crocodile domestique les quatre
personnages vont être contraints de
faire équipe à noter également que pour
les 25 ans du film culte de James
Cameron Titanic revient
exceptionnellement au cinéma en 3D une
bonne occasion pour la Saint-Valentin à
venir